I think everyone on this list is going
to be difficult to describe that might
be partly why they're so fascinating
my name is Devendra Banhart and this is
styled mo the caucus
so the caucus they were born out of the
creativity and chaos and commotion of
Haight Ashbury in the 60s but they were
so radical they were their own thing
they were anti-capitalist
common anarchist genderless completely
wild explosion of creativity founded by
hibiscus it was the main first cockade
they would perform around San Francisco
and they would do their own versions of
cabaret shows and famous Broadway shows
but what makes it special what's special
why they style stars to me it's that
they really knew how to walk into a
thrift store and see a lampshade and say
that's gonna be a hat and to see some
curtains or an old shower row shower
curtains and say okay that's gonna be a
skirt and they just reappropriation
spaced on these disparate materials that
you would find just like a fish caretta
and the garbage dump er at a flea market
I think next time you go to the thrift
store and you see anything just consider
making it at making it a hat and we'll
be honoring them to some degree they
helped me open up that bottle of glitter
and just let it go you know I'm still
shaking off glitter for my view it's
think to them okay second style icon
Georgia O'Keeffe Georgia O'Keeffe you
don't know was one of the great
modernist painters consider the
modernist vision or abstract
expressionist painter United States she
was dedicated completely disciplined
artist whose main focus of courses her
work that didn't stop her from looking
fabulous
the her most famous work is extremely
really bright and colorful landscapes
with skulls and flowers right colorful
flowers her personal style is very
minimal very monochromatic black and
white Georgia style is so perfectly
sharp elegant we should put on the throw
and a hat and just looks fabulous and
you're ready to go and I that's so fun
it's minimal it's subtle but it's also
about quality over quantity too you know
she provides like three very very nice
throws as opposed to 5 million cheap
ones you know her real name is toto as
well they're a little known fact which I
really love it's so cute
it kind of changes the way you see her
because she's kind of imposing and
daunting and so sharp unimagined should
be so cheap I cut right through it with
a couple of words and I think she could
but those so there's a gentler side so
in that gentler side I'll call her toto
my next style star hero is George
Costanza dress based on mood George is a
real style girl to me he has this
strange
grungy collegiate I've given up kind of
book it's like really gently given up I
like that
a lot of plaid goes for that autumnal
thing which I really appreciate if you
ever wondering what to wear you know
just dressed like a pumpkin you're good
to go
jeans with Cortese with these the
Cortese shoes and jeans it's a good look
it's a great look especially if you're
bald love the hood I remember playing a
show once and somebody kept yelling
George Costanza I knew I didn't
understand then I realized oh yeah I'm
wearing like a very green sweater with
the orange shirt blue pants I'm doing
the George look the Bowery is a legend
everybody loves Leigh Bowery everybody
should love Leigh Bowery Leigh Bowery
was an Australian artist who made kind
of made his debut in the under London
scene a part of the New Romantic club
scene he was a performance artist and a
designer we've made the most amazing
outfits in the world that are still
totally inspiring people that are still
a source of wonder and magic inspiration
and really that kind of thing were you
just looking at the entire world is
something you can utilize I mean Lee
infamously said flesh is my favorite
fabric in fact did a performance in
London where he's this huge creature
this big outfit and he's doing the whole
performance and moving around and
suddenly starts heaving and heaving
heaving and then out from between his
legs
a woman pops out she's been cradled to
him actually her face I think was in his
crotch the whole time and then finally
she like burns out this woman later
actually into becoming his partner just
a real fearless designer and a real
fearless performer I mean like when I
say fearless I mean not impeded by their
own fear no one's fearless we're all
full of fear but can your fear guide you
or lean into it and embrace it my next
style hero if I know Brian Glenn was a
writer
Glen had a TV show on public access
called TV party it was a huge influence
on me and all my friends hi and welcome
to TV party it was a show where he
really just had his friends stop by and
his friends were Joe Michele Basquiat
and blondie me and Richard Hal
all these amazing artists and he was
kind of this embodiment of cool to me a
remember as a kid seeing him and just
going like oh wow you're just cool Glenn
was known as the style guy for Jimmy you
know it is a classic style but he's
definitely paying attention to every
element of that I always loved how he
didn't take fashion too seriously but at
the same time he cared about it and at
the same time you knew how to dress well
and he knew how to make a good joke
about about the fashion world and I
think that's important to have that
sense of humor his vibe super funny I
met him a couple times in real life and
he was really cool he had he was just
somebody who's present and isn't really
altering that the way they behaved for
the rest of the world she's a really
rare thing you know that somebody who's
got some rooted in themselves or just be
themselves in every occasion and I think
all these people that I've mentioned
have a sense of humor even I mean even
the fact that Georgia O'Keeffe's middle
name is toto there's a little person C
and we're in there and I'm sure she was
the funniest I have all of them I'm sure
so that's an important thing too you
know you it's like take let's take
fashion seriously but not ourselves so
seriously a reverse that maybe don't
take fashion so seriously would take
yourself seriously actually don't take
yourself seriously that's for sure so
yeah fashion seriously just not yourself
[Music]